so this is I remember you we don't find
out a thing in the screen everyone was
building out the episode like oh I can't
wait till he sees whatever you and it's
like I don't know what about work
nothing hey a lot of people said the
same thing to me and when I finally
watched it was kind of like why yeah
it's like pointless yeah I mean like
okay so Marceline and the Ice King
hangout and nothing else I mean nothing
else uh no this really good episode
assistant yeah okay well okay so this
one everyone watching this probably
knows this episode but uh Ice King is
looking to write his latest ditty and
with Delta lyrics and yeah he pretty
much goes to Marceline's house cuz
apparently they have a history though
even he's not entirely sure what the
history is and Naruto of course walks in
the frame because he wants to distract
me as always and uh play fetch assistant
yeah cuz he knows I'll distract me
thanks you ready huh you're getting
distracted hallo ready for the camera
nartu ready go for it
Jared go boy sister oh did I get
contracted a Cepheid soon everyone wants
to see ratchet - bodega see there - yeah
uh anywho uh so uh so girls are
Marceline's plays and he just wants to
write a song with her and she's like
don't you remember anything don't you
even know why you want hang out with me
don't you and like nobody I just want to
write a song and so what so they pretty
much are writing this song and he thinks
it's cool if he has like a tortured past
or whatever so the radio into his past
room yeah yeah
the the UH vive past room was that it
wasn't the deep past room or Devo bet I
don't know the pastor of be the pass to
be the pastor yes it was a good which
was a great job um and Gotha there
brings all his old writings of stuff
which he thinks are like just really
tragic lyrics and hmm still smells like
tears yeah it's still wet from my tear
what she thinks it's just great because
that means you know just oh princesses
dig sad guys you know so was the author
that was brought up before which is the
white member Finn was reading that had
that book it's like it says in there to
be mysterious and Jake's like no girls
no that's right the I remember oh that I
didn't catch that
um and so they're working on this song
uh and Marceline is just frustrated
being around him but doesn't we don't
know why yet and then we find out that
through going through his writings that
he's really lost not only his sanity but
his memory of who he was uh to that
crown that we found out about before and
uh he's having fun as okay and yeah so
pretty much she starts reading going
through all the lyrics and apparently uh
he came before he went crazy to look out
for her quite clearly after the
apocalypse there's no sugarcoating this
now I mean it's the friggin apocalypse I
mean that you see the city on fire
everything's destroyed I mean there's
just no dancing around that now and uh
and he gives her a doll and it looks
like he's sort of took care of her for a
while um I don't know if it was what was
it after she was a vampire can we see
the two bites on there you don't see the
bikes you don't see the body she has
little flames in the hole in the ears
okay so she could be pretending to be a
vampire
probably not but at some point became a
vampire that's why yeah I mean she's
like oh I like playing as a vampire so I
can be event but unlikely so well
stuffed animal the Ice King gave him
remember that one uh danske gave her
yeah sorry her uh her uh was like an
octopus ish thing right no no a little
bear with the and that first time we see
it it's the I was falling off her
boyfriend's right here yeah that's
married huh okay so and we pretty much
find out that they had this whole story
together and the Ice King is pretty much
just
gone I mean mentally and but she's still
singing with him you know and she's got
a little - you're going down or I and
stuff just jamming cuz it's like she's
both really frustrated with him but also
cannot but also cannot let him go either
because all he's done and it's this
great big tragic story um and it's it's
pretty effective merit oh okay the bet I
was doing good okay like I play fetch a
little bit and let's just wrap it okay
I'm telling the story I'm getting
through the story and then he he did
that okay he'll not me I was saying
focused go um I'm sorry dude it's not
your fault actually it is it is gonna
lower yeah oh okay well how dare you
then go on
so okay um so okay so that's the story
oh and yeah it's it's much more serious
one obviously but there's still again I
like there is still a little bit of
comedy it's it's more tragic that is
funny but it's still kind of like just
that he does not get how this happened
he just hears these really awesome
layers like yeah I'll make me sound
really pathetic not make me sound really
sad and he's just not getting it I
really love those moments where it's
again kind of like where where they
discovered his past it's just this
perfect mix of you know it kind kind of
funny but also really sad it just
creates that really kind of
uncomfortable bittersweet you know that
you know but you know it's like there's
still Jim and he doesn't have the memory
but and I think anyone that like
whatever has a friend or grandparent or
anything that you know suffers from
memory loss or you know uh or even just
a person changing and forgetting what a
person was like I mean could sort of see
this really kind of identify mmm that
you know the idea of just losing someone
while they're still there mm-hmm and
yeah it was a very it was a very legit
good episode and I like how much we
learn and I like though I did kind of
call it a little bit oh is the last
thing I'll say before Oh
oh I kind of called it because yes we're
done well because there's that one
episode I said the last one where we
fight about the ice King's past to where
you see his video so he dresses up like
Marceline and he's singing and I was
like wait do we ever see them together
now if we were song together well also
cold actually when she had her book went
when Finn and Jake were in Marceline's
closet hmm and she's like I'm gonna
write about to sing about the deepest
darkest things on her book from red said
Gunther on it yeah that's right and you
called that you're like wait a minute
why is that on there then you forgot all
about it
obviously you tell my wife oh what'd I
say
I'm smart oh but uh and yeah and I was
like could they cuz when he puts the
krona that's when you know everything
starts going south and also like you
know that I won't say somewhere there
was a hint that she was a child like
while the city was burned while
something wasn't fires and we saw
something like that before right yeah
for being a kid and they so you know I
was like well maybe these two kind of
connect or whatever and yeah I really
like that they've gone this they gone
this whole time without connecting these
two characters you know in front of your
face at least uh but also kind of makes
sense because they're not characters you
would normally think would be together
Ice King and her kind of like they're
not even polar opposites where it's like
oh hey would it be fight to see these
two together they just they just don't
seem to go and you can't imagine like oh
the possibilities of Ice King and
Marceline
so like hey don't actually see a
connection like you don't look at me go
there could be a possible connection
there yeah I mean it's it just based on
their character oh shut up not my fault
um so yeah I thought this was really
nicely done it had much more drama to it
than comedy and it revealed a lot of
good information about it both
characters really and uh yeah I thought
was really good
Jory I I mean saying too much cheapens
it for me I don't know I just it really
surprised me I mean I
I have my ideas and and it's just so
beautifully done and I think you're
absolutely right you hit it right there
it's for you know if you know anyone
that's had some sort of memory loss
dementia Alzheimer's something to that
effect you know you get it you see it
and it's like it's funny but it's not
and I don't know it was just it was
really sad and really sweet and they're
two of my favorite characters and
together and so I mean it's just it's
really really good it's it's I I don't
know I'm feeling feelings yeah it's just
really nicely done for a silly little
cartoon that's funny and sometimes
pretty neat and has a really good
backstory this is the one that where I'm
like well you don't like it just
they know what they're doing it makes
sense and I get it and it's really I
think difficult for a person like myself
um I like watching cartoons
I like watching anime but it's not like
I give a damn I mean it's like drawings
drawings you know but like this episode
I care about Ice King I care about
Marceline and my jaw dropped on the
floor when I realized the extent of it I
figured there was an ice king Marceline
thing going but I didn't realize the
whole you know I think my most favorite
part that is so bittersweet is what he's
the lyric she says where he he had
written down um I'm trying to save you
but who will save me and I was like oh
that just is all sorts of I don't
know all sorts of I'm serious today that
was serious there is a something yeah
there is a it wasn't Twain I know it was
like the Sunday morning show it I don't
know but there was this reporter who did
the story about his wife who was um who
is losing her memory and I forgive it's
all timers as I forget to echo what it
is but something were her met
Marie was over time you know sort of
fading away and a lot of her brain was
just fading away and to a point where
they finally put her um you know they
put her in a hole and he would always
come visit her and he would just you
know she can't remember what happened
five minutes ago you know and one of the
things is that you know they tried to
help receive what she remembers and she
constantly talks about this guy who is
clearly the husband and she would always
call him mister you know uh this may
just may feel so happy so happy all the
time and he's right in front of her yeah
you know and you know and he see what's
you know what's his name and she just go
uh mr. happy you know just really happy
right and it's one of those thing you're
just watching this and your heart is
just ah so any is one of those things we
start looking you realize yes sir the
tragic comedy of this that she's talking
about guy who's right there but through
that it's just also the most
heart-wrenching thing and I think when
you see her playing the guitar again the
tear in her eye and hinges play I mean
just so into anew so happy playing this
in some ancient what up what a
combination just what a really really
nice of a nice balance there so how
about you um I realized Gunther low in
the beginning of course you have the Ice
King dressed up as Marceline it has been
and doing the Frey song but Gunter you
gun turd my fries or my good turn and
he's like dude you love me and then you
seem go huh
with a little heart is like it should be
that one now uh something I really do
remember I really do like go to this
what do you say it's a lot of a few
times where the Ice King is really
legitimately nice to gun to whichever
country it is you know and just see to
and got to really looks like oh like
this is really nice like he's really
sort of it was actus ecstasy and a very
wanted there and they stopped and he's
like oh and he flies and marsley just
waged a Gunter he's like who just walks
away little guy yeah pretty much but he
didn't fly ice-cream carried him the
whole way yeah
um no when I saw this one like it
definitely shocked me
I mean it was an extent yeah I kind of
saw it coming I guess you could say
could not like like the extent of it in
a sense yeah okay I kind of guess they
may have had a past or something but
starting at such a young age starting
before he fully lost his mind and you
connect a teddy bear now and going back
to it remember what she was saying about
it
that's her most prized possession after
how many hundreds of years yeah has
passed that says something about that
bear and then finding out that it was by
the Ice King it's like wow that actually
kind of has more significance to it I
think he was still Simon at the time oh
yeah Oh Simon sorry um
and then I mean let me put it this way
what is interesting um I am uh oh my god
I have seizures I'm epileptic and when I
started realizing this was going on went
to the doctor and I took a simple test
there are three objects that were shown
to me and God
Thanks destroying you know I I am
turning that's option moment I'm trying
to invade activist of a consolation is a
person saying if they can make it a
cards against humanity' Saturday what
you are hosting the phone is off the
phone is off oh sorry no uh is three
objects I had to remember and talk to me
for maybe five minutes and then I had to
recall what they were I only remember
two out of the three I could not
remember for the life of me the third
one and keeping it they have to
understand though he's got an
extraordinary memory I mean more than a
little bit above average with his memory
normally most part I guess pretty
amazing I'm so irritating but like the
scariness that it is that to not
remember something that far away like it
was oh five minutes ago I should
remember these you know so like Ice King
just not remembering anything it kind of
like shakes me a bit because of that
it's like wow I'm this young and I don't
remember you know three objects
he doesn't remember like anything and
then when he broke down during singing
he's bawling shooting at this guy going
why can't anyone love me why does no one
love me and you know
Marceline's like stop doing this why are
you doing this he's like no no no keep
going while he's still bawling yeah like
he doesn't even realize why he's so
upset
it seems noe that you're absolutely
right I got that too I felt like he did
he didn't know why he was upset but he
knew he was upset but he was certainly
gonna use this yeah for the you didn't
know where he was getting these emotions
and feelings from but hey they work this
is awesome and then when she pulled out
you know the picture and was looking on
the back is like you wrote this to me
it's like oh this is good sing it and
Marceline space it's like you don't even
remember writing this to me and when how
heartfelt and everything those lyrics
were just to not be able to remember you
writing that you know it's a scary
feeling for I think anyone and you know
anyone that has dealt was someone I've
never done with anyone that had that my
uncle he had it but he lived in
Louisiana yes and he died in it in his
40s no was it 50s 50s or 60s from okay
he had early on yeah and it was awful it
was fast but I mean ever I never dealt
with him specifically so I've never been
down that path but god I would just
imagine how Marceline would feel or how
anyone would feel who actually deals
with that that's got to be one of those
stab in the heart every time you see
them you're so happy to see him but then
they don't remember you at all or the
good times or bad times you've had and
it's just like you know stabbed in the
heart you know well and is something I
had to remind myself is that you know
Marceline and Ice King I mean it I keep
forgetting you know there were a couple
hundred years old something like
thousand about okay about a thousand
years old
you know and when she's discover I mean
she's you know a little kid and he's you
know he he doesn't map the crown on its
head so he's going through his
transformation if even if you know she
had some of the hair in his year blue
and he's carrying the crowd yes
hanging on his belt yeah so but he's not
he doesn't have a head like the whole
time you know I mean he's still taking
it off every once a while so I mean
that's not just like a long time that's
like an unnaturally long amout of time
and it kind of makes more sense to why
you didn't always see them together
before you know you can see probably
some point she's like dude I have to
have something normal mentally to
connect I just I can't be around you you
know and I'm sure I go chase princesses
or you go do that uh and you know the
price this long period of time where
they just won't see each other and then
what they meet up it's like oh like
these feelings are back again you know
and on top of that maybe new
disappointing ones of how far gone is he
yeah you know so it's uh a yeah it was
really it was like you said there's
hints here and there you get a little
bit of a feeling but not quite to this
extent you don't think they're gonna lay
this much that they were really dealt
with they really dealt with this and not
on this scale
yeah in the show so it really did sort
of come out nowhere uh one thing that I
really like certain good enough going
back to the first episode where
Marceline is introduced um remember
she's been traveling around and she's
been finding new homes consistently this
episode brings up potentially the reason
why she says I'm always looking for a
new place to go and you always end up
finding me yeah that's right yeah yeah I
do that was so bad a member yeah she
trying to this and say you know and it's
and she doesn't even know why he keeps
coming around so I mean it's one of
those yeah where it's like wow they end
again I don't know if they planned that
in advance probably not but I mean a
great way to just connect the dots I
feel yeah and I think there's um I mean
it's something where I mean people can
argue whether or not it's selfish or you
just need to save your own mental sanity
but you know there is something
where it takes an unbelievable amount of
commitment to you know and like I said
sacrificing your own sort of mental
status to look after someone who has
something like what the Ice King yeah
yeah you know and she probably knows I
I'm not fit to do this you know I just I
can't do it I'm like I said whether you
want argue that's her trying to save
herself and it's her being selfish well
whatever angle you want to take you know
she split from him and said I need my
own life
well okay human beings we live for or
what counts I guess you can say 70 years
you know because you take out because
even if you live to 74 the good first
ten years of your life it's kind of like
you're just growing up you know maybe
okay well girls say a hundred years
imagine ten times that yeah living for a
thousand years and they're both still
called young there's no signs of them
you know especially her I know she's you
know but technically you Nora what she
appears to be yes I think personally and
I'm probably wrong and but I really
think that she wasn't a vampire right
away and sometime when she was a
teenager she got bit and so she's aging
but she hasn't aged physically anymore
because of that well they're they're
both aging but it's kind of like the
crown is making him immortal yeah to a
certain extent or at least extremely
slowing down his aging process and the
fact that she's a demon yeah and a
vampire yeah it's completely slowed her
down so you know bringing up the whole
thing of is it selfish that she needs a
long time yeah anyone that has to deal
with that now imagine dealing with that
for an eternity there there is a
difference between a lifetime and ten
lifetimes I always say you know like if
people had to deal with you know someone
that has is some sort of you know it is
some sort of mental imbalance you know
whether it be like extreme depression or
bipolar or whatever that you know
whatever you have um depending on how
extreme it is I always say look there's
nothing wrong with you know being with a
person has depression bipolar any of
that but I mean just be
prepare it takes a lot of commitment it
takes a lot of sacrifice
you know just if anything it's not fair
to the other person to not be ready for
that yeah you know to to not commit to
that well our friend's mom has MS yeah
and ever since it was at least high
school right no in height well she was
already paralyzed in high school but I
remember in high school and like I think
our sophomore year she was still able to
drive like in one of those special like
special van things cuz she was in a
wheelchair but she was still able to
drive us but I mean like that's all he
does now this has to take care of her I
mean and it's he does it and he does it
because he loves her and all that stuff
at the same time it's like I can imagine
just wanting to break out and for a day
and go do something you know and
sometimes you just can't it's kind of
scary it's if that ever happens to you
I'm throwing you in a ditch I won't kill
you a little three units that's your
causes until you exactly Oh me someone
clean this is um well you know what
hello no I'll go to I'll go to like one
of those mattress pad oh great Doug's
house and throw me on his bed there you
go take care of me I don't want to take
care her she's just a handful just my
challenge yeah but your wife is too nice
she would take care of me she won and
that scares me too sweet this always
scares me see you later
so like she'll take care of me sorry we
had to get up at such we talk about
those these incredibly serious matters
that we're talking about where we're
gonna dump your yeah yeah like every
other day isn't a discussion about where
you're gonna ditch oh by the way I did
really love this one had a more delicate
balance of comedy and drama the one uh
holly jolly secrets it was like comedy
comedy common common man yeah you know
and I can see even after that impact it
kind of be like well it could still be
taken as a joke or the so the other
thing like how you were seeing with two
glasses huh
but like this one was a lot more of a
delicate balance where he's like it was
one of those where he's like one of
these and Marceline goes up and you seen
her face it's you know just a cartoon
and she has just tiny eyes no nose and
olenska but you just kind of see what
just the added lines how happy and sad
she is at the same time and then he
tries to kiss her and he's like no what
it was this like moment and then it's
like that's got to be disgusting for her
because she doesn't look at him that's
your bad there yeah yeah and then to
tossin on top that you know he doesn't
even remember anything it's like well
it's like that's the only man funny yeah
that's like the ultimate I don't say
insult but the UH the ultimate a moment
where it's like you really are gone
because you I mean you don't even know
like our relationship ya know I mean cuz
he to see if they were always like what
why yeah I know and you know and you
know it's it's just sit here a while
none of this is clicking at all um cuz
when you push the win he was like good
cigars I got ya even they think that's
it even though there were funny moments
it was still kind of sad even when you
really I mean even when he like runs to
the fridge and jumps up but I'm so sorry
I didn't mean to push you
I'm so sorry you know what it would be
the cat yeah and if person's like
everybody's like a cat hahaha but at the
other hand you're still remembering like
oh my god this is so pathetic like
here's this man that took care of her
and you know is pretty much a father
figure to her and he's like a freakin
cat and so sorry I didn't know I mean
it's just it's funny but it's not funny
and it's this episode did that a lot in
a very very good way yeah I think it's
one of those where you can actually
watch it again and a lot of stuff that
you know we were laughing at we could
look at now like oh yeah like that's
that's pretty good shaking now actually
watching it I think you're right
compared to the Christmas one where it
just slammed it on you at the end I mean
and to me it's like everyone's like you
it took as a punchline no I see it as
both I see it as this great big dramatic
that's unbelievable and but putting it
there makes it unbelievably funny as
well yeah in this one it's very much
it's very well paced you know sort of
segue a decline uh you know of just
going from something really happy and
goofy and singing a Gunter and stuff you
know to just this you're learning more
and more and there's even a few times
it's like I'm laugh a little bit but
it's like you saw like the laugh just
got fewer and fewer and smaller and
shorter and I'm like was all sales yeah
and then it's just like okay even like
with Finn and Jake like you know oh what
are they doing I have no idea like that
would usually get a laugh here just like
oh well I did love when Jake and Finn
and Jake busted in and they're like oh
you already happen Hey and Jake goes up
and does this other voice regular voice
I don't like how you treat women you
know I didn't think some of this is just
like I you can leave them what an excuse
like yeah what yeah you know it's one of
those because she's like get out get out
get out but upon him just getting
tangled up in the cord she sees how
pathetic he is it's like well crap look
at bud I guess yeah yeah so um yeah it
was great watching this and looking at
both of them cuz obviously I already
know what was coming and watching their
reactions
Jory was I was expecting you to cry
honestly I was expecting you to start
crying Doug and I looked shocked and I
wouldn't be surprised by solid to your
coming down your cheek neither of whom
cried - bastards right there
it was it it really takes it takes a
forget lot for me to cry at something oh
yeah
like it's like I'll say this if this
episode was maybe it's perfectly paced
it's fine the way it is if it was maybe
five minutes longer
it probably won't got me give you just a
Lexie I'm very much I like vogner music
I like music that takes like you need
hours for something to set it forever it
- you know it has to really lower my
defenses that usually takes time yeah um
but but it just doesn't all me it's not
very emotional
oh yeah you know and
well done so um yeah good um I can say
why your about talks about it like you
know I can true I can't wait from to see
this I can't wait to see what it's
something when I'm with it for you guys
to see though no that's why do you want
to see I'm not gonna tell you what it is
Oh fine because okay this would have so
much of a build up your expectations are
so high so you know it's a great episode
just look I like well okay everyone said
it was great so it is a people talk this
damn thing up and I was like oh god here
we go
you know and ya know you all were right
ya know this really good right hold on
though you I don't know about you you uh
know anytime you hear people talking up
stuff you ain't silly knock it down like
10k
and you're like it's probably gonna be
completely under garbage yeah so of
course this is gonna work for you well
now of course is gonna be that you're
surprised at where it's just so friggin
good that even added ten more of those
pays 10 more on top of it it's just
people build up so much expectation for
something in and I get it and it's it's
it's weird because on the one hand yes
obviously if it's amazing you want
everybody know just how freaking awesome
and amazing it is but then if
everybody's saying that you're like oh
yeah it's probably not calm down yeah
it's I it's Tom cuz I know where people
are coming from to like you know this
had such an emotional impact I mean I
really want you to have the emotional
impact too and I want to I want to talk
about cuz I still it's so good I still
have emotions about how I share those
emotions with you so go watch it so we
can share those emotions it's like I get
it I know why people build it up but yes
it can a can backtrack - I actually have
stuff that's been built up oh no sir
like oh okay it was good that's not why
I'm telling you if it comes with me but
you like it or you hate it then we can
talk okay okay okay fine now you know
everyone's gonna be like what's the
episode what's the episodes most people
can probably guess what it is honestly
it's not like it's not some bizarre
strange episode well maybe no matter
work happens we're actually coming upon
a few episodes that I really really
enjoyed one made my jaw hit the floor
one got me teary-eyed and the other one
I was just like wow
they took Finn and they put him through
the ringer
well we get upward episodes Wow so the
Lich Finn the human and Jake no no oh
it's down the road a bit I mean those
aren't the next ones we're watching hey
I think the dog was going to say
something uh I was just gonna say shut
up so we can get to those okay yeah you
have obviously both of you added nothing
to this so yeah no no one no so glad I
hate people hang I'm not leaving this
time screw oh yeah I just wanted to get
my drink well just all sit here and play
turbo with each other though maybe mouse
devil sister be like yes he's on there
drinking all the time will sponsor you
oh my god that would be great
Mountain Dew please it is all G drinks
we do give half our paycheck to you
anyway yeah this I don't difference so
oh by the weight really quickly as the
last thing I want to say there's I don't
care
Taco Bell they have a new flavor of
Mountain Dew lots of new flavor no no
obscene just an actual do Kazuma Lee at
the Baja blast
they now have a sangria flavored one of
Mountain Dew yeah it's horrible I like
it is pretty good imagine something
horrible at Taco Bell so go ahead and
try it it's better than the Superman one
Superman yeah that a Superman flavored
uh nothing do oh I'm so glad this
episode could get us talking about deep
things but it all comes back to Taco
Bell and not do at Mountain Dew so with
that said later you ever have those cine
mini bites no they're incredibly look
kind of gross they're taco bell ones
yeah no I know like I see the picture it
looks like it's pooping really really
happy I liked our caramel apple apple
empanadas no that's gross oh I just like
your table goes fabulous I miss Lecter
tacos that's the one thing you don't get
there
dr. Turk oh you know what I had recently
the chili
a cheese burrito or something to that